Okay, so now we'll look at sessions. Very simple construct. It's built off of
the main premise,
again, that I personally use in my trading. We'll remove structure for now, and
we'll focus solely
on sessions. So there are three main sessions. There is the Asia session in
blue, the London
session in green, and the New York session in orange. And the main premise for
me really,
and what I look at is liquidations and reversals based off of sessions. And
there's no need to go
to in depth here. You can just use it as a principle. For example, what I'm
looking for in London
session, a lot of the times if Asia gives a range, what I would like to see is
a run of one side
of Asia and a continuation. And so some solid examples of that, again, I am not
cherry picking
anything. I'm just looking at the most recent price action. So you want to
combine trend
and sessions primarily, for example, we're in an uptrend right now. So you can
see we have Asia
session. Asia finishes. We sweep below Asia. That for me is a confluence that
it's time to go long
in the London session. And even just taking out the other side of Asia is a
pretty good
construct. And we can look at it. Again, trending, we sweep lows, we take highs
, trending bullish
after the shift. We don't sweep any lows, but we do trade higher. And so this
is pure logic,
obviously, in a situation where Asia is literally on the absolute swing low,
you're never going to
expect to sweep Asia and continue higher. It's not going to happen. So these
are usually the
instances where you'll see, for example, an Asia session get protected and
London opens and, of
course, we end up continuing higher. Again, we have a swing low down here, a
swing high up in here.
You have Asia session range. What do we see? We see London open sweep Asia
expansion to the
other side of Asia. And again, this is something that you'll see quite
consistently. You want to
be pairing it with trend. This is an example where we don't see that. Why don't
we see it?
Because we have a swing high. Asia is a swing low. So when Asia is a swing low,
it's unlikely that
we're going to open up, take out a swing point and then reverse. It would be
untradable, even if
it happened in that case. And then in here, you can see Asia, we're actually in
a bearish move here,
primarily. So in the bearish move, if you've got to expect a continuation, and
here we don't,
this is the point of reversal, which is fine. But typically speaking, Asia
sweep to the other side.
And it's something that happens, honestly, quite consistently. We're in an upt
rend here,
Asia low sweep continuation, right? If we're looking in here, we have Asia,
get swept, London expands. And then, of course, you'll have situations where
you take one side of Asia, and you just continue because you're heavily
trending,
take one side of Asia, you continue, heavily trending. Those can also happen,
right? You don't
take Asia and you just continue. Again, they happen. Don't take Asia in this
instance. Asia
remains untouched here. And then sweep Asia reversal. And so it's not just a
rule that you just like,
if they sweep Asia or reverse not, but so many times you will find that the
London,
the trending move of London comes after a run of Asia, if Asia is in a
situation where it should
be liquidated. And that's the primary way that I honestly use. Again, you can
see clear uptrend
Asia, take, and then the move occurs. And so this is, if you go look at the
backtest in,
one of the main things for my London session setup. New York session, a little
bit different,
but still based off of the same principles of kind of intercession relations.
So New York
session can either give a continuation or a reversal. And again, really does
depend on context.
Context is always king when we're using anything. And so if I give you some
ideas of context again,
just random price, no relevance to cherry picking. That's not what I'm
interested in.
I'm just going to give you as is. So you can either take two situations. For
example, the most common
is if you're trending, you'll get a London continuation. So you can see we're
trending bullish here,
right? This is all bullish trends. So we have London and then New York, you
want to see some
type of sweep in New York and you get a continuation from New York. London is
trending. We've taken
Asia, there's no need to come all the way down and below this level. So we get
a sweep below
and a continuation, right? In here, we're still trending and we get a
consolidated New York session,
which is kind of avoid. It's just NA. It's not for or against. And then there
are also reversals
where you'll take out London's high and then you'll be expected reversal. Again
,
it's context here. You just understand logical obvious things. We've had an
absolutely insane
run up, a crazy run in price where price becomes overextended. When price has
been so heavily
aggressively in toward buy side, you have to understand that in these
situations, market makers
aren't in a great situation. Their books are imbalanced. If you don't know
about market makers,
I'll make it very simple for you. The largest market maker in this space is
Citadel and their
entire job is to provide liquidity to both sides of the market. So if you want
to buy, but there is
no seller available, Citadel will be there to provide you the liquidity you
need to execute
your position and they get paid based off of the spread. That is how Citadel
make their money.
Well, one arm of Citadel. Of course, you know, Citadel as a bank. Maybe you
know the institution.
They also have a very large market-making division. When price becomes, this is
advanced
institutional level understanding, but when price becomes really overextended,
you have to understand
that buyers have been dominating the book for the entire day and the entire
morning. And so there's
no opportunity really for if you're a buyer and there's not enough liquidity on
the sell side,
Citadel will be here providing you liquidity at these levels. The higher that
price goes
without pullbacks, without congestion, the deeper drawdown Citadel are in for
their market-making.
Plain and simple because they're selling to you and they're not able to, they
're selling to you,
but they're not able to buy back from any sellers because buyers are so
dominant.
So when you become so overextended, you take out a key previous high level, you
're literally
going to expect a reversal because there are so many pieces of information,
data points,
confluences that are in favor of a reversal. And so that's where you use this
session for a New York
sweep London and reversal. And so it's almost context profiling, which is to
some degree
discretionary, but sometimes you can objectify it. So those are the types of
market environments
that you'll see a reversal, the type of market environments where you'll see
continuations.
And typically that's what it will be. It'll be London will trend and New York
will either continue
or depending on the context, New York may provide a reversal. So if you are,
let's say, for example,
bullish, right, and London was actually a consolidative pullback move, then
that's where you might see
a New York session as a sweep of London and a continuation for the trend. But
let's say you're
bullish and London is the continual move when New York session opens, it will
likely play a
continuation from that London session. Yeah, kind of a game kind of simple.
Some examples of that are, as you can see, we're trending London gives the
trend New York opens
and gives a continuation kind of same thing here open continuation. This is an
example of where
prices moving kind of towards the lower side, we have really a stagnant London
session,
and we get the sweep of London and reversal. That's another thing as well. When
you get a
consolidative London session, again, these are all context profile. But when
consolidative London session, right, a lot of the times these are where you're
more often see the
sweep reversals, where you get the sweep and reversals and expanseves, you'll
typically get
continuations. For example, these are the continuation moves when it again
contextually makes sense.
And so primarily sessions are used for that. Asia is really just a liquidity
pool on the
highs and the low side, because London needs that liquidity to fill orders. And
London session
is the one that sweeps Asia. And then New York session typically has London
continuation or
sweep of London and reversal again, dependent on the context. That's how I
primarily use
my sessions as you'll see in the edge and the back test in itself.